hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich habe heute ein richtig
cooles rezept für euch ich werde nämlich
muffins machen für den kindergeburtstag
und zwar werden das ganz normale
zitronen muffin aber die deko ist ganz
besonders denn da konnten schöne
regenbogen obendrauf und eigentlich habe
ich mir auch vorgenommen gehabt den teig
auch einzufärben haben sich aber dann
doch dagegen entschieden habt dann
schöne bunte muffin förmchen genommen
und habe einfach gedacht die deko weder
schon grund genug und ich bereite jetzt
erstmal die deko zu denn die muss erst
mal trocknen und später mache ich dann
die muffins und noch ein bisschen sahne
und so weiter zeige ich euch also für
die deko braucht ihr einfach nur modelle
schokolade
ich habe die hier bereits schon ein
bisschen geknetet erwarte mir auch immer
hier in so gefrierbeutel auf und dann
einfach in so einer tuba schüssel dann
sind nämlich sehr lange haltbar und es
sich einfach dieses deko schock was ihr
von mir kennt wo auf der einen seite zum
beispiel hier mein zelt drauf ich da
gibt es nämlich so ein an leitungs video
und ich habe sie in verschiedenen farben
die einzige farbe die es nicht gibt es
gelb aber die kann man sich ganz gut
einfärben und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
das mache ich jetzt zuerst habe ich
etwas weiße modell ihr schokolade und
die habe ich bereits eingefärbt also
sieht man hier und zwar mit der
lebensmittel verpasste gibt man einfach
ein paar tröpfchen mit dazu und da
könnte eben auch sehen dass man die
super 1 werden kann mit diesen passten
so und dann einfach schön verkneten
und dann haben wir gleich ein schönes
strahlen das pink gelb
zu suchen ich denke halt immer penig
also insgesamt habe ich jetzt hier sechs
farben das geld habe ich mir jetzt
eingefärbt das orange habe ich mir auch
gemischt und zwar aus dem fertigen brot
und etwas gelb hat es am einfach
miteinander verknetet und dann entsteht
eben dieses schöne orange und ist jetzt
die farben für den regenbogen die ich
benutzen möchte und ich mache jetzt
heute insgesamt 24 regenbögen denn ich
habe 24 muffins denn auf seinen
kindergeburtstag darf man nicht so wenig
haben und ich kann mir das ist alles mal
kurz schön weich und dann fange ich
direkt an zu formen
jetzt nehme ich hier meine sondern
presse um da so lange strenge zu
modellieren ihr könnt sie jetzt im
prinzip auch einfach so unternehmen aber
ich möchte ganz gleichmäßig haben und
deswegen nämlich die von damp presse
dafür dann nehme ich jetzt vorne diesen
diesen runden aufsatz
dann wird es hier so geschraubt und
jetzt kann man ganz einfach durch
drehbewegungen vorne diesen strang
herauspressen
ich habe jetzt übrigens hat den aufsatz
gewechselt und damit liefert den mit den
also mit mehreren löchern den darm drauf
sagt wahlleiter bis zu groß das hat
vorher schon überlegt dass es vielleicht
zu dick sein könnte aber dann werden die
regenbögen einfach viel zu groß
das heißt sie können zum beispiel machen
wir es auf eine torte setzen wollte also
mache ich meine strenge mal eben kurz
noch mal und setzte dann auch direkt
farblich aneinander
jetzt kläglich die einzelnen stränge mit
etwas zucker kleber zusammen zu kleber
besteht einfach aus wasser und cmc
pulver als zellulose pulver und hab ich
mir jetzt einfach ein bisschen heißes
wasser mit etwas zellulose pulver
angerührt das genaue rezept schreibe ich
euch dann in den block jetzt müsst ihr
das schnell zusammenkleben
vor allem müsse darauf achten lieber
arbeitet er langsamer also in mehreren
schritten macht kürzere strenge denn
ansonsten trocknet euch das ziemlich
schnell aus und kann dann halt auch
brechen und es dann einfach immer schön
zwischen rhein und zusammenkleben
weißt du was mich diese inhalte ich weiß
nicht kennst du die sendung regina
regenbogen
das habe ich früher als kind immer
angeguckt echt nicht eben nicht so viel
älter - nett aber ich habe eine andere
sache gedruckt und meine schwester der
mann gesagt am ende des regenbogens
wartet der traumprinz das hat sich
eingefunden
ich glaube schon im irak glaubt ja auch
noch daran dass es am ende des
regenbogens was gibt aber ich glaube sie
glaubt er an die gold schafft die kommt
dann noch ein paparazzo schwabe von
daher
naja wir basteln und den regenbogen
lieber selber
jetzt schneidet hier dienten einmal
gerade ab vorne
so und jetzt habe ich hier so einen
kleinen auf stecher also das ist so ein
runder ausstecher und da lege ich das
jetzt hier so drumherum und ihr seht
schon das bietet sich ja dann auch immer
mit das heißt wir müssen das einfach
noch mal um abschneiden aber jetzt erst
mal rum legen dann nehme ich den
ausstecher weg
dann scheint es hier unten nochmal
gerade ab
und dann aber wunderschöne regenbogen
treffer für unsere muffins
b
so sehen jetzt die ganzen regenbögen aus
und ich musste jetzt erstmal trocknen
lassen damit diese später überhaupt
aufstellen kann
deswegen ist es auch wichtig dass man
die zuerst macht und dann eben erst die
muffins und ich richte jetzt mal schnell
die zutaten für die muffins und spätere
die zutaten noch wird die creme und
während jetzt die deko noch trocknen
kann kann ich schon mal den teig
zubereiten ihr könnt ein prinzip jeden
beliebigen teilnehmen egal was ihr wollt
was euch am besten schmeckt ich mal
wieder meinen leckeren buttermilch
steigt weil da die muffins einfach
richtig schön saftig werden und dafür
zeige ich euch mal die zutaten ich habe
hier drei eier eine prise salz 150 gramm
zucker 90 milliliter öl 450 gramm butter
mädels dann brauche ich eine koppel
vanille extrakt versteht man hierüber
kann nämlich eine bio zitrone davon die
schale und ein bisschen saft ich habe
525 gramm mehl und eineinhalb packungen
backpulver und es ist jetzt ein ganz
normaler tag deswegen geht es jetzt auch
ganz schnell also die eier kommen jetzt
in die rechte dann die prise salz mit
dazu vanille extrakt vergesse ich
oftmals am anfang kann man auch gleich
mit rein nehmen und den zucker und jetzt
muss das erstmal schaumig gerührt werden
und in der zeit für mich ich schon mal
backpulver mit dem mehl und kann schon
mal die zitrone abreiben
und wenn die eier masse dann schön
cremig ist gebe ich die buttermilch noch
mit rein und das öl die letzte truppe
auch noch dann auch die zitronenschale
das macht das ganze halt so richtig
aromatisch und schmeckt halt dann auch
sehr gut als ich bin der totale der
zitronen fan
deswegen gibt es bei mir manches
zitronen cupcakes oder zitronen muffins
aber andere sachen sind natürlich auch
sehr lecker
dann habe ich mir ein kratzer hier
eingemachte sich auch nicht schlecht
nicht mehr immer aufpassen
und dann kommt auch etwas zitronensaft
er mit
ich bin jetzt einfach den saft von der
ganzen zitrone
das wird ganz kurz unter kredit mit also
auf niedrigster stufe
jetzt habe ich einmal mehl und
backpulver hierdurch dann gibt es auch
keine truppen
wobei mein manager immer so fallen das
ist ein normales weizenmehl aber das ist
schon ganz feine 210 mails und 405 und
die zitronenschale
die aus gepressten die schmeiße ich
übrigens nie wechseln gibt es immer mit
dem die spülmaschine messestand wie
sowieso eine spülmaschine und der hat da
immer komplett die ganze kohle
aufgebraucht also die schale benutzt ja
immer den saft benutzt und dann eben
noch den rest und dann kann man sie
wegschmeißen
dann lohnt sich auch eine bio zitrone
und es wird jetzt einfach ein bisschen
untergerührt
und jetzt fühle ich den teig gleich in
meine vorbereitete muffin form ich
möchte diese hilfe eines spritzbeutel da
kann man nämlich sauberer arbeiten
man könnte jetzt aber auch zum beispiel
einfach ein eis portionierer nehmen das
geht auch ziemlich gut aber mit dem
spritzbeutel hatte halt echt gar nicht
also verschmieren gar nicht uns geht
vielleicht schneller
wisst ihr was kriege ich noch rein
dann verschließe ich das oben jetzt
einfach mit so einer klammer dann läuft
mir das auch nicht aus könnten auch
gummi benutzen geht auch gut und
schneiden wir unten jetzt eine spitze
weg nicht so groß und können das besser
einfühlen und ich nehme dafür jetzt
meine papier also diese papp förmchen
ich stelle sie trotzdem im ende muffin
form ein damit sie einfach nicht umfalle
und ich verschiebt es jetzt auch dann
nicht und es passt immer ganz gut und
dann einfach so etwa bis zur hälfte
und so werden die muffins im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze für ungefähr 20 bis 25
minuten gebacken
danach hat sich sie komplett abkühlen
und dann stellen wir die dekoration noch
ganz weg
wenn der machen sind jetzt komplett
abgekühlt und so sehen sie aus
also ich habe es jetzt wirklich einfach
hier drin stehen lassen und jetzt kann
ich schon mal die creme vorbereiten
entweder von der sahne creme nehmen mich
zum beispiel quark oder er macht mit
frischkäse buttercreme und das ist es
was ich heute machen werde weil die
frischkäse buttercreme hat einfach den
vorteil dass sie wenn sie kalt gestellt
wird fest wird das heißt später können
meine regenbögen wenn ich sie dann rein
stecke einfach nicht zu verrutschen und
dass ich meine klassische creme wie
immer halt und ich habe ca 250 g weiche
butter 250 gramm puderzucker und 250
käse jetzt geht es zuerst mal die butter
hier in die schüssel
bei uns heimisch total war total
sommerlich und winter tier total
aber das wetter macht ihr euch zu
schaffen
echt anstrengend dann gebe ich den
puderzucker mitteilen den sie sich
einmal durch
das fröhlich jetzt schön cremig mit dem
flacheren erstmal auf niedriger stufe
und dann schalte ich mit anja
und dann gebe ich hier noch den kalten
frischkäse mit rein und lass es einfach
noch ganz kurz verrühren
das könnte man jetzt zum beispiel auch
einfärben mit den lebensmittel
verpassten aber ich lasse es weiß denn
ich sprich zeitgleich wolken
jetzt steht frischkäse buttercreme
fertig jetzt bereite ich mich in einen
spritzbeutel vor mit loch thüle und zwar
die lochmühle 11 millimeter im
durchmesser und ich brauche jetzt auch
kein adapter weil ich auch nicht
auswechseln und stellt es hier in den
spitzboden stehender rein dann habe ich
beide hände frei sodass kann sich hier
kurz ab
jetzt fühle ich hier gerade die creme in
den spritzbeutel 1
jetzt könnte das oben entweder auch
wieder mit der klammer zu machen oder
einfach zu drehen und jetzt spritze ich
hier ein paar wolken drauf
einfach so ein paar kleine punkte
ich setze meine muffins schon mal um um
sie dann in den kühlschrank zu stellen
da hab ich jetzt einfach so eine
transportbox
die ist dem hübschen reinstellen im
kühlschrank stellen kann nämlich die
creme schon mal fest werden
und wenn dann die regenbogen aus wie
schokolade auch schön hart sind kann ich
dir einstecken fertig
jetzt ist die creme etwas fester und
jetzt kann ich die regenbögen einfach
draufsetzen
super guckt man jetzt ganz vorsichtig
drews dir mal hin
ich stell dir mal raus ganz ganz
vorsichtig mit beiden händen rein
ganz ohne zur tiefgang
die samira spült jetzt hinter mir noch
ein bisschen das geschirr ich mache dich
okay okay und ich darf hier fertig
machen also die machen jetzt fertigt sie
müssen auf jeden fall wieder gekühlt
werden
bei uns hat jetzt auch gerade ich glaube
wahrscheinlich 30 grad draußen in der
küche genauso der ofen war warm und das
schmilzt ansonsten gleich wieder und ich
stelle jetzt hier wieder schön rainer
kann man es ja auch darin schön
transportieren in diesem cup cake
transport spender da zählt auch richtig
hübsch aus man muss nur aufpassen dass
es hier immer schön eingehakt ich
ansonsten fällt euch dieser träger
einfach runter und ja ich mache das
jetzt gleich in ihr dürft schon mal das
rezept nachlesen auf cellestis blog.de
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken ich finde es sich was richtig
einfaches was aber total viel eindruck
macht vor allem erinnern mich diese
regenbögen an diese eine süßigkeit
ich glaube das ist für haribo oder so da
gibt es diese süß sauren regen bogen
teile
das heißt wer sich das vielleicht sparen
will kann vielleicht auch einfach so ein
regenbogen nehmen und einfach ein
bisschen drüber spannend in die creme
hat man sogar noch einfacher
jetzt wünsche ich ganz viel spaß zum
nachbacken und wir sind nächstes mal
dann immer noch